a big weekend for that guy right there
Kevin Hart was in Las Vegas for his
third annual heartbeat weekend I mean he
just takes over sin city but you know
what the real moment was when Kevin took
time out of his crazy schedule to make a
dream come true for a little boy
battling leukemia Jacob has been has
been dealing with some some tough issues
you know deal with leukemia and he
spends a lot of time in his bedroom so I
said why not go to this boy's house and
revamp renovate and change this bedroom
in one of the most massive ways possible
Jacob loves muscle cars from
understanding so I mean he's got the TV
the stuff on the walls and I love this
the drawers are basically they're there
to imitate like toolboxes like oh let me
get my tools but instead it's closer in
there
oh man Jacob just broke down a little
bit and almost made me cry what's up man
how you doing you like it yeah when you
first walked in and saw this what did
you think thank you so much for all of
this and just can't put it in words of
course it wouldn't be a Kevin Hart
moment without a little comedy check out
what happened before jakob's dream
bedroom reveal I'm uh I'm gonna try to
figure out when I hi you want to hide in
a drawer so you wanna hug that's just
not funny Kevin that's me okay I'm to
lay down with his carpet and I could
just fit in the white spot and so he
comes out and just stand up cuz it's
white and black that's the only reason
why I wore this outfit was because of
the carpet but I'll tell you what you
can't hide you're gonna look like one of
his teachers dress like a woodshop
teacher Frasier I'm checking my
birdhouse he won't stop he won't stop
love him but I gotta tell you Kevin is
not stopping here he along with rally
health and britty cares are gonna
continue to help bring hope to kids with
cancer you did this in Las Vegas will
you replicate this across the country
with Kevin now we'd love to ultimately
it's not about me it's about the
children it's about the people who are
in need and the solises there was not a
dry eye in that house and gritty cares
is a special special charity by the way
I'm not mad at Kevin that he said I look
like a woodshop teacher but i do want to
mention that behind all the jokes
there's a massive heart and that's why i
love hanging out with this guy